you know what there's nothing better
than being a co dad you got that right
bratty crew families working as one
cohesive unit we got a big surprise
no move back and forth the Christians
not doing the backup note I just said
that like together Christmas like a
normal family and their Christmas hello
grandpa Kurt
my dad's gonna scoff at everything we do
nothing's ever good enough and your
father hasn't met the new of all dusty
me who wouldn't be impressed with you
man
dear God it's gonna come off we're dusty
but he's beautiful
there you go why don't you bring the car
around we'll meet you at the curb right
away sir
I mean no I'm sorry I'm not the driver
no I'm Brad just stepped out and why is
he here cuz my dad's coming to these
total lack of masculinity I mean he's
weak chin and soft underbelly bothers
you not a bit you know I'm just getting
the feeling maybe you guys would like
some privacy
I just want to find the perfect together
Christmas tree you don't think I can
operate a chainsaw
[Music]
don't you shut up
this is getting good boy
[Applause]
ready and white game
you